we have great teachers but we also have
teachers that are failing our students
that perhaps should not be in teaching
and how does how does the State address
that because the way they've been
addressing it does not work for the kids
it works for the teachers to have that
job and stay in that job meet Julia
macias a high school freshman who lives
in California San Fernando Valley I plan
on going to an Ivy League college such
as Harvard MIT most likely leaning
towards the sciences like astronomy or
physics and while julia is currently on
the honor roll there were times when it
seemed like her effort wasn't paying off
being a kid in the California system
right now is a lot like the lottery you
might get an amazing teacher one year
and then a not so amazing teacher and
you see your scores are reflected upon
that because I remember having my scores
go up and down like I'd like score
really well one year and then the next
year I'd go down like 200 points which
is a big big gap so when she was in the
second grade Julia's parents went to
meet with her teacher and got a
surprising response her teacher Tino
mentioned that she's just not good in
math that there are kids that are good
in math and there's they're not and she
wasn't one of them because maybe she had
a learning disability that she did all
that she could so Julia's parents got
her switch to a different class where
she flourished she's telling me coming
home excited doing her work and she says
dad oh my god I never knew there were so
many ways of doing things and I thought
what can you attribute that to because
it's the same girl the settings change
different teacher the Macias is
experienced with ineffective teachers
led them to join eight other students
and become part of a lawsuit known as
Vergara versus California the case took
on labor statutes that make it difficult
to get rid of underperforming teachers
including the permanent employment
statute which gives a teacher tenure
after just 16 months on the job and the
last in first out statute which forces
districts to lay off teachers based on
seniority and not
performance in fact the dismissal
process is so convoluted that experts
testified that out of two hundred and
seventy-five thousand teachers in
California only two are dismissed each
year on average for unsatisfactory
performance and the process itself can
cost taxpayers hundreds of thousands of
dollars in legal fees in a ruling last
June that was widely hailed by education
reformers a Superior Court judge found
in favor of the plaintiffs writing
substantial evidence presented makes it
clear to this court that the challenge
statutes disproportionately affect poor
and or minority students the evidence is
compelling indeed it shocks the
conscience the California Federation of
Teachers denounced the verdict and vowed
to appeal the decision we believe the
judge fell victim to the anti-union anti
teacher rhetoric of one of America's
finest corporate law firms that that set
out to scapegoat teachers for the real
problems that exist in public education
in California Teachers obtain permanent
employment by law after only 16 months
on the job Joshua Lipschitz a lawyer
with gibson dunn & Crutcher argued on
behalf of the plaintiffs and the
dismissal statutes are really what make
up in some ways some of the core
protections of teacher tenure in
California because they create an
extraordinarily difficult set of hurdles
that a school district must clear in
order to dismiss a teacher for any
reason I'm tennard right now but if I do
break the law or if I'm acting
inappropriately I can still be dismissed
it's not a guarantee for life Gabriella
ibarra is a fifth-grade teacher in Los
Angeles and a member of the California
Federation of Teachers she's been in the
classroom for 18 years and hopes the
vergara ruling will be overturned we're
focusing on performance by just test
scores versus looking at the whole
picture every child comes in differently
with different experiences and
backgrounds and skills and for us to
expect every teacher to bring every
student up to level takes time taking
our rights away doesn't help us be
better at what we're doing it's just
putting a negative image to everybody
else that we're not doing our job
properly but the Vergara case isn't
about taking away teachers right to
tenure nor is there any system in the
United States that relies solely on test
scores to evaluate a teacher in the
classroom their own experts testified
that three to five years would be a
better amount of time to decide whether
a teacher is deserving of tenure which
just makes sense it gives teachers more
of a chance to prove themselves and it
gives school districts more of an
opportunity to look at data and see how
the students of those teachers are
performing instead the teachers unions
really spent the whole case focusing on
why tenure as a concept is important and
that's something that really was not at
issue in this case in fact many of the
teachers use as examples of poor
performance in the Vergara case
displayed numerous indicators of
incompetents that did not rely on
student performance a fact that was
supported by many educators during the
trial throughout the entire case we had
lots of teachers who came out to support
us testified on our behalf and and
really explained both to the public and
to the court to the judge that having
ineffective teachers in their schools
and in their midst is terrible for them
and terrible for the profession as the
decision moves through the appeals
process the vergara ruling has already
prompted advocacy groups in other states
to take action last month a group of
families filed a similar lawsuit in New
York in cases are expected to be filed
in Connecticut Maryland Oregon New
Mexico Idaho in Kansas though it could
take years for the courts to make a
final ruling Julia macias is busy
focusing on her future I do have another
goal of making kids aware that they can
and do have the ability to succeed in
life with the right type of education I
find it very important to have that goal
heard and my voice heard
click below to see more from recent TV
and subscribe for all of our latest
videos